but as some of it is also
morgan uh muhammad ali style
being good enough at uh
doing everything you need to do without
giving enough
meat for the reputational attacks not
being afraid but not giving enough
meat i don't see why the people who have
good ideas have to lead lives that are
that clean
if you can do it you can be messy yeah
you should be able to be messy that
otherwise
we're we're suppressing too many people
too many two billion minds
yeah can you believe elon musk smoked
the blood
i still people tell me this that okay i
have discussions about elon and people
uh the avi loeb
the harvard scientist yeah who's talking
about amo amoa
that it might be alien technology he
told me
his this outside the box thinker
yeah when speaking to me about elon
said called him the guy who smoked he
smokes weed
he's the blunt in a dismissive way
like this guy is crazy because he smoked
some weed
i was looking at him i was like why
wow wow i think you should be able to
have consensual drug-filled orgies
[ __ ] perfect lives yeah you should be
allowed to be messy
you're right i take back my statement
i'm just saying respectability
is the unique prison where all of the
gates
are open and the inmates beg to stay
inside
it's time to end their prison of
respectability because it's too
effective of a means of sidelining and
silencing people
including it is better that we have bad
people
in our system than this idea
of no platforming people who are beyond
the pale
because it's such a simple technique so
how do we
uh what's the heroic action here on the
well for example having ashley matthews
on my program
by the way she was absolutely um
delightful as a guest she was
she is polite in the extreme far more
polite than i am
and i had her right after roger penrose
uh as a guest because i wanted to
highlight this
program can go anywhere we can talk to
anyone what about social media you've
started highlighting
people being bad on social media uh how
do we
fight this like if you get banned from
social media so you're saying nobody
will stand up to me
well just figure out what your incentive
structure is before assume that they're
assuming i get banned on social media
because somebody wants to make sure that
my message doesn't
interfere with the dominant narrative
okay
what will happen by the way i'm very
glad to be able to explain this on your
show because
that video will presumably be archived
and they can't easily make
you take it down okay so
what's going to happen is that there'll
be a whole bunch of very low quality
bot like accounts that
dog you every time you talk about right
dude it's getting old getting boring we
already heard you dude that was
like let it go not a good look not a
good look it's one of my favorites
but what about the high profile ones
well then you'll get a few high profile
ones and some of the high profile ones
command armies right like at some point
i had 10 000 people
using exactly the same templated tweet
uh tweeting at me it was just actually
it got to the point where it was funny
because everybody said did you
did you hear that in hipster coffee shop
and i was like why are you all suddenly
talking about hipster coffee just
hilarious um
those things will cause you to think
better of it you'll start to see your
follower can't
go down because it's easy to give you a
bunch of bot like
follows and then just pull them so i
think it's pretty well known
how and then maybe your account will be
suspended
and it can't be revoked and you know et
cetera et cetera and then three days
later
you'll be told it was an error so let me
push back i just don't see
not defending you like okay so what are
the things you would do
that given that i can actually talk to
you yeah offline
that that would uh make me not defend
you
uh well first of all i can't
i mean no but i can imagine yeah but all
of us
have things if somebody says do you hear
what your boy
lex said about you what what did lex say
about me
oh he said you were flawed dude oh [ __ ]
yeah you know they so
distrust because none of us want to
stand behind flawed people
that's why you have everybody rushing to
say i neither condemn nor condone i know
i don't condemn narc you know why what
is that
we're all trying to say for the record i
said that eric
is smarter than me and a brilliant human
being but flawed like all humans are
my point is i've now come up with a new
policy which is
i don't care what my friends have done i
am not disavowing my friends
not because they didn't do the wrong
thing maybe they did do the wrong thing
i don't know what's the value of
friendship if you
if that's not that like for example
we've had this situation with brian
cowan
brian cowan was featured recently in the
los angeles times
i know nothing about the allegations i
can't
i didn't even know brian at the time
right i've known him for
roughly the time i've been in los
angeles maybe a year and a half
during that period of time i've never
seen anything wrong
now i'm in a situation what do you think
he did do you think he didn't
like you know what i don't know but i do
know
this everyone's entitled to have friends
because we can't afford isolated people
and if your friends do the wrong thing
they're still your friends
yeah and if they do terrible terrible
things you bring that up with them
privately
and it's not my responsibility to
disavow in public
you know we've had this situation that i
don't like
where you know particular people that
i've been close to
i'm put under tremendous pressure to
disavow them what do you think now about
your buddy
i like dave rube and all that kind of
stuff here's the thing just because my
friends are my friends
i don't disavow my friends we all need
to make a statement that we will not be
brought
under pressure to disavow our friends
our family members
because mass murderers
are dangerous the more isolated they
become it is
not a good idea to constantly push to
isolate people
yes and it's dangerous and so it sends a
signal to everybody else to uh
to fit in to be more extremely cynical
about the human so my feelings
i find out you've been selling heroin to
elementary school students
you're still my friend and i will not be
disavowing you
and if i have a problem with you selling
heroin to elementary school students
during school hours i will bring it up
with you
privately because we don't need to hear
my voice
added to that condemnation are there
things that you could do
that would cause me to say actually f
this guy yeah above and beyond that
but simply doing the wrong thing i think
we've gone down a terrible path
i think isolated people are about the
most dangerous thing we could have
in a heavily armed society so i i deeply
agree with you
on brian cowell and on all these people
that quote-unquote got cancelled
uh and i'm not saying that they i don't
i don't know the truth value because we
can't
and even if i did know the truth value
i'm not setting up an incentive
structure
for the personal destruction as a
means of letting institutions combat the
fact that individuals are the last thing
that can say none of you guys make any
sense
you